يتم الآن تلقيح أكثر من 80000 شخص يوميًا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
، ومراكز مثل هذه
هي التي تقود
الحملة
التي تم تسليم مليوني جرعة من اللقاح ، أي
واحد من كل خمسة من السكان ،
وبحلول منتصف مارس تخبرنا السلطات
أنهم  تأمل في تلقيح أكثر من
نصف السكان البالغين في
الدولة
، والعملية بسيطة جدًا مثل أي شخص
أمريكي يبلغ من العمر 18 عامًا
ويقيم هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
بعد حجز موعد
وانتظار يوم أو يومين تحصل على تذكرة
انتظر  بضع دقائق تملأ بعض
الأوراق
وفي غضون دقيقتين ستكون
داخل إحدى هذه الغرف ،
مرحبًا يا رفاق ، مرحباً
إذا كنت في الولايات التي ستنتظرها
لأشهر لهذا ،
نعم بالتأكيد كيف تشعر بشعور جيد ، نعم
عصبي
إنه لقاح جديد ، إنه أمر مزعج للأعصاب ،
كيف تشعر أنك بحالة جيدة ، حسنًا ،
حسنًا ، تهانينا ، لقد
انتهيت للتو من اليوم الثاني ، إنه لقاح جديد ، لقد
انتهيت من جرعتين
وهي رسالة مماثلة من عشية
لقد تحدثنا إلى
كيف تشعر أنني
متحمس جدًا لديك هذا اللقاح
أي تحفظات أه لا على
الإطلاق أثق في القرارات التي اتخذتها
الحكومة وهي من أجل سلامتنا الخاصة ، لذلك لا توجد
تحفظات تأخذ نفسًا عميقًا سيدي
مختلف مختلف  أوه ، هذا كان
لا يمكنك حتى أن تشعر به حقًا أن تكون
صادقًا معك
حرفيًا ثوانٍ
حسنًا عزيزي ، خذ نفسًا عميقًا
، لا أشعر أنه
موجود بالفعل ، لم أشعر أنه من
السهل جدًا عندما يكون الأمر كذلك
لا أشعر بأي شيء بعد
مشاهدة
لقطة تلو الأخرى تذهب إلى أحضان الناس.
ذهبت للقاء
المدير العام لهذا المركز هذا هو
لقاح cinepharm آه دعني فقط أريكم
ما لدينا هنا كم عدد
هذه التي تتناولها
كل يوم لذا متوسطنا  من
التطعيم
3000 ونقوم بإعادة تطعيم الأشخاص
بعد 21 يومًا ، هناك من لديهم
تحفظات بشأن أخذ
اللقاح لأولئك الأشخاص الذين تقول لهم ما
هو مقبول دائمًا أنه أقل خطورة أن تأخذ
اللقاح الذي يحتوي بالفعل على  المرض الفعلي
ولا سيما مع ارتفاع أرقام فيروس
كورونا هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
إنها رسالة تدفع الحكومة
بقوة أكبر من أي وقت مضى
جنبًا إلى جنب مع المزيد من الضغط ، إنها
تضع لوحات إعلانية
تشجع الناس على الحصول على اللقاح على
الفور وهذا الجدار يقول كل شيء حقًا
شكرًا لك.  يقول من
أبطال الخطوط الأمامية لدينا
برنامج تحصين رائد عالميًا هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
والذي سيساعد
ليس فقط الإمارات ولكن
بقية العالم
على الوقوف على قدميها التي أقول
إننا
نحييكم بيكي أندرسون CNN
أبو ظبي